the order 1886 is that later this week
on various computer game consoles our
review of the game will be up on
Thursday this week but today gets gotten
a bit of flack it seems some folks in
the UK put up with speed ro novice a
completely getting five hours Justin
what's the deal well a lot of people
have been concerned that there's gonna
be a lot more to watch in this game than
there is to play some YouTube guy had a
early copy of the game apparently put up
a five hour run and the like I mean
about half of that was was cutscenes but
but the developers have responded saying
that is not actually in the full game
that's not a an accurate representation
of everything that you're gonna be able
to play yeah and I mean we'll we'll have
a full answer pretty soon we have one of
our guys in the office Kevin man or yes
is playing the game right now yeah I've
gone by to check it out every now and
then but at the same time I don't know
that it's that huge of a problem that it
would be a short game what do you think
like if it's good enough like $60 for a
new release game for five hours if it's
a 5 hour game that's way too much like
telltale has telltale just like five
dollars in episode and you get like an
hour and a half and that I can see yeah
and like the whole series is what like
25 and you get maybe went like six seven
hours of me play but I think $60 for
five hours if that's true is like it is
but at the same time so it's I mean as a
because I work in the game industry I
actually don't get a lot of games for
for free but yes the mind work doesn't
actually involve a lot of gameplay yeah
I pay for my own games and I buy them on
Steam really cheap or I wait for them to
go on sale so for me it's usually like a
ten twenty dollar investment so for me
that that link doesn't matter as much
because I'm just gonna buy it when it
gets to that sweet spot mmm like South
Park at 20 bucks that was perfect that's
not super long game but 20 bucks like
totally worth it for a 15 hour 12 hour
experience
and the thing that sticks out to me with
this is like for instance my brother or
folks who don't play that many games
every year though he'll pick up a Call
of Duty and he'll pick it up on launch
and it'll cost you know $60 and he
doesn't play multiplayer so basically
how he's playing a single-player game
for $60 so what do you think
why is it like when it comes to
something I call a duty where so many
people only play single-player or so
many people only play multiplayer that
we're like more forgiving there than we
might be with something like this you
know part of it is that that excitement
of playing that game even if you're not
playing it you know multiplayer with
your friends but having that experience
along with everybody else like there's
some movies that I'm gonna go see in the
theater like I know it's not worth it if
I wait a couple months I can just see it
on Netflix or see it on the like rented
from Amazon online but sometimes it's
worth it just to be able to be a part of
those conversations with everybody else
and say like hey like that part that
happened in that movie that was so cool
and games can be the same way but it's
so much of it's a much bigger investment
like asking someone to say to spend $60
on day one and then spend six hours or
seven hours rather than the one that
this reminds me of actually is have
either V played spec ops the line yes so
spec ops was a not a long game there was
no multiplayer component to speak of
yeah and it wasn't the best shooter in
the world but it was one of those games
like you were saying Justin that people
were talking about and I remember not
picking up when I first came out but
there was so much buzz around what that
game was attempting to do with its story
that by the time it dropped down to
about 40 bucks I was like alright I'm
gonna give it a go and then I felt like
I have my money's worth what what did
you think when you played it I don't
know I see I thought this story was very
impactful it sort of reminds me of I
know that game was well it can 8th
that's like an eight-hour story in spec
ops I blew through BioShock Infinite in
like 110 hours sitting right paid $60 on
launch and I got it and it was fine I
did the same actually I was going on
holidays and had to complete it in one
night cuz I'm almost boiling it was
worse but I thought that spec ops
aligned was powerful enough that I
didn't really want to finish it I didn't
really think oh I just spent $60 and
only got 8 hours of entertainment and
you really think about it in that way so
I think it has a lot to do with I think
what the games trying to do and how
people take the content like if you only
have a single-player story and it's you
know eight hours but it does it does
what it does really well and get you
engaged
I think that's money well spent but if
it's feels like it's you know missing
something it can understand why people
get upset about spending that much well
and then we also have that juxtaposed
against games that don't have a story at
all that are either $60 or is in some
cases free I've spent hundreds of hours
in hearthstone
I and I've paid a bit of money not not
$60 worth but I I like 700 or so you
know I'm not keeping an eye on it like
$2,000 yeah but you know that's
something that has a lot of gameplay
whether regardless of how much money you
put into it it's something that you can
take in those small parcels I'm never
gonna sit and do a ten-hour stretch for
I'm just gonna play a hearthstone for 10
hours but whereas Bioshock that's
something I will sit and just run
through the first time and I even played
that one the second time because I like
wanting to do it the harder difficulty
both because I really enjoy the story
and I wanted to get that experience
again but also to prove like I can do it
at a harder difficulty so like how do
you gauge how much gameplay there is
like is it if it's worth it to play
through a second time then it's suddenly
twice as long yeah so weird I guess like
the answer to this is the really obvious
answer is that if it's good enough then
yeah it's worth the cash and so to that
point the order 1886 how many you guys
played us do you think it's AI obviously
the version that's in the office at the
moment Kevin's playing none of us have
played that's under embargo anyway have
you played it at any events I have what
do you think cause I've played it a
bunch I know I know how I feel about it
so mention why you think first well you
and I had this conversation at the
PlayStation experience it was the same
every demo that I've played at the game
so far I feel like I can't pass judgment
on it because every demo I've played is
some variation of cutscene and then a
close-quarters combat situation a
PlayStation experience they had you you
grapple down the side of the blue one
the same thing and then you're in a
tight little little bit corridors but
yeah like a house you're in a house and
you're shooting from the top and then
you're shooting from the bottom of yours
clearing enemies out of a room and it's
still very very close you know and then
another one you're in like a kitchen
that's sort of set up like a maze and
you're always you know this far away
from your enemy and I feel like I
haven't really gotten got enough time to
like explore what the game has to offer
right now I just see it as like a
hallway so I'm interested to see what
else there is
that's like the problem with vertical
slices like that that we get at these
conferences but the problem that I
thought every time is that whenever I've
seen trailers of us it makes it look
like a regular linear third-person
action game and when I play this like
people are saying like oh it's like a
Gears of War type thing you know it's
like a year in a bit since the consoles
can't come out and here's a really
good-looking you know third person
actually but what I've played it it's
felt so
on Rails in comparison to any third
person action game like it makes games
like SpecOps the sections that I've
played feel like like their open worlds
like where you can like take different
angles and you know attack the
objectives in different ways whereas
whenever I played the order it's it's
been like shoot that guy in there shoot
that guy there press triangle and then
do this thing and I look at this piece
of inventory so it feels a lot more like
like heavy rain like a yeah feels more
like it Resident Evil 6 and that's not
in terms of like I don't say in terms of
quality because like that's that's not
what I'm getting up but in terms of like
here is a section of a game play it the
way it's meant to be played if you don't
you die go back to the stars every demo
I've played it's felt like that so like
that's the worry like I think there's
this week's gonna be really interesting
when those reviews hit yeah yeah I I'm
interested to see what Kevin thinks
about it I'm interested it try it out
myself
I like you said it's weird it's hard
when you're only given a small part of a
gaming you're not able to really
experience all the different parts of it
and what we've seen that isn't
necessarily indicative of the whole game
we're also told like the same things
that everybody else hears there's a lot
more to it there's all these different
things and like that's what we know
about the game and you know we hope we
expect different things but it is it's
weird that it's set up like a shooter
when what we played doesn't quite feel
like that yeah I guess we'll find out
pretty soon at Thursday 5 a.m. Pacific
as when the embargo lifts on the order
1886 will have a review up on gamespot
calm that's 8 a.m. Eastern yeah that
should be a pretty interesting we'll see
we'll see later in the week how good
that game is let us know what you think
in the comments below